mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
start with rectangle abcd
construct an overlapping semicircle cps
as shown
if cq has a length equal to 10
the question is what is the area of
rectangle abcd
i adapted this problem from amman's
maths blogs
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
we will get started by considering o the
center of the semicircle
if the semicircle has a radius equal to
r then o s is equal to r and c d is also
equal to r
that's one side of the rectangle
we also have oq is equal to r and oc is
equal to r
now suppose that the rectangle has
another side length ad that's equal to x
that means bc also has a length equal to
x and ob has a length of x minus r
we'll now consider that the area of the
rectangle will be one side multiplied by
its other side so it will be equal to x
times r
we want to figure out x times r and this
is how we'll do it
we'll consider the right triangle obq
we can solve for b q using the gogu
theorem b q squared is equal to r
squared minus the quantity x minus r
squared
we'll simplify this a little bit and we
get b q squared is equal to two x r
minus x squared
we'll put this equation to the side
we then go back to the rectangle and we
consider the right triangle cbq
we can again solve for bq by the gogu
theorem
b q squared is equal to 10 squared minus
x squared
we thus have two equations for b q
squared
we can set them equal to each other
now recall we want to solve for the area
which is x multiplied by r
in this equation the negative x squared
terms will cancel out so we get 2xr is
equal to 10 squared we then divide both
sides by 2 and we solve that x r is
equal to 50 and that's the area of the
rectangle
incredible
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you